my name is Portia and I'm a beauty and
fashion influencer and I'm in London
today with glamour UK and we are going
to be talking to Hackney laces women's
football is on the rise and with it
a strong vibrant and inclusive community
Hackney laces is a perfect example of
this what I want to know is what does
being a female footballer really mean to
these women and how our iconic female
footballers such as Franco be inspiring
a new generation I first say playing
football when I was 14
you know without football there's not
really in me I really started playing
from when I slide coaching girls on the
fence and I thought you know what this
looks fine and interesting I'm gonna
give a go myself
football was literally the thing that
was that yeah this is what I really want
to do right guys so what we're gonna be
doing there today we're gonna start with
a warm-up gonna have many races for
about five minutes
oh cool we'll be in groups of four just
trying to keep the ball away from the
defender just passing around as far as
long as you can yeah I'm excited I'm a
bit scared though cuz I don't a husband
put ball but I'm excited I'm excited so
where did you find Hackney laces your
friend managed to put a girls team
together ten years ago maybe longer okay
so before that there wasn't a girls team
not that I know of the first one went
down they it was fun everybody's really
welcoming and the social slide is really
really good as well which is primary
school I've been interested in football
I was in the girls football team and
because I'm very boisterous yeah I don't
like makeup football was literally the
thing that was that yeah this is what I
really want to do so you are a proper
we fan aren't you yes definitely I am
yeah Fran Kirby is the top UK CML
footballer that faced a Chelsea and the
England national team she has had to
overcome many adversities in her short
time already including knee and ankle
injuries which she came back from after
having to take time out over two years
this makes her a great role model for
young players building their confidence
in and out of the game she came back
from injury she's really hard-working
and she's just like a great role models
for the young females out there do you
feel inspired by her when you see Franco
be on the telly was because she's on a
professional level so it's a fact that
she can bounce back from your injury and
is just able to get on of it yeah it
kind of motivated me as well
watching her it's given me more
confidence in getting up and kicking the
ball for me I find it like really
relaxing I look forward to it really
it's like therapy like for every
definitely treatment how does it make
you feel being a part of a team like
that it makes me happy you know it keeps
me going keeps me fit what advice would
you give to young girls that are trying
to get into football I'll say it go out
there give it a try and most point for
me is are you having fun today has been
so amazing being able to be a part of
the team with the Hackney laces it's
truly inspiring to see all these women
from different backgrounds in different
styles shapes and sizes enjoying
football and being so active if you want
to see any more videos like this just
subscribe to glamour UK